yes it's dark
i'm wondering how long we can only stand
it
without picking up our phone
and turning the flashlights on
seconds
minutes
a whole hour
don't worry i'm not going to give you my
whole speech in the dark
but it's something i'm used to
for more than 10 years
i
and two million people back home
have been living in darkness
locked between two borders
that are nearly impossible to live
literally
in an area that spans
25 miles long
and about 5 miles wide
i am palestinian
and i am from gaza
i grew up there and i still live there
in gaza
we have a whole lot of nothing
and i aim to create something from that
nothing
when a community is cut off from the
world all what we need to do is what is
to think outside of the box
way outside of the box
that thinking
led me to two projects
to address
two serious issues in my community
the need for building materials and the
need for electricity and energy
two essential ingredients of life
both
are in lack of supply in gaza
first
i'm not here
just to talk about the occupation we
have back home
the siege
the wars the bombs the protests
or the death toll
i am here
because i wanted to show that we can
live
through it all
i am here because i wanted to make a
change
i'm here to tell you that i am a
statistic that cannot be ignored
in 2014 war
thousands of houses were
destroyed those houses
were made from sun
baked stones and blocks
those houses stood for decades and
decades
those houses where for my family friends
neighbors
everyone i know
and that time i ask myself a question
what can i do for people
how can i help them
i knew
we weren't able to get cement
aggregate and sand to rebuild what the
world destroyed
but also
maybe we can use something from inside
the community something we already had
i started to put things together
first paper as a filler instead of the
aggregate we import
but that did not work out
what about using glass powder
to replace part of the cement but that
failed too
i guess making building a blocks out of
mud would be a great idea
but unfortunately it didn't work out
during the process of burning the muddy
blocks
we had a huge amount
of ashes
and i was like why not we don't use
those ashes
the idea flashed in my mind let's use it
and combine it with the rubble of the
demolished houses and make building
blocks out of it
after more than 150 failed experiments
and over six months of research
i actually made it
[Laughter]
i created
a building
block out of ashes and ruppel of the
demolished houses
it's here
it came all the way with me well it came
before me
[Laughter]
so it's lighter
it's cheaper and it's stronger
[Applause]
this building you block
of course you ask yourself how this gear
do how does gear do it it's not that
hard that it's not that easy
first
we collected rappel from all around gaza
strip
then we combine it with the ashes that
came from the landfills
when the recipe is done it's time for
baking
so we mold the blocks as you can see in
the photo
and we cure it using water steam
i call the material green cake
and people now can use it not only to
rebuild or house old houses but also to
build in new complete structures
green cake so far has created jobs for
more than 30 people
and
we we were able to rebuild around 50
apartments each one of them is in size
of household that almost for eight
people
we also trained
frischy graduates
female and male which is not very common
in the community
and we got several awards locally and
globally
this block is not just only building a
block it changed the stereotype about
women in gaza that is stated it's this
type of work is meant for men
education
is the strongest weapon we have to fight
for our freedom decent life and future
my background helped me to do this proc
i went to the islamic university of gaza
and he studied civil engineering where
there was one to sex female to male
ratio
everyone told me i will ended up without
a job
i went for a major that meant for men
but their lack of encouragement did not
deter me it inspired me
[Applause]
after this long journey with the block
and after two years
what gaza did what gaza does need just
not just only building blocks we also
need electricity we need the energy
i developed a new
company called sandbox
sunbox is a smart solar kit that we
source from china and we engineered to
fit the market need
it powers not just only light but also
laptops phones internet connection a fan
or a tv
we teach local vendors and technicians
to sell install and provide customer
services for people
we got the project of the ground by
providing 15 families with solar energy
one of the solar units we installed in a
refugee camp the next day i came to
check what happened with the solar and i
found a whole new neighborhood watching
a football match using our device i was
like wow
that's gonna create a huge impact in the
community
that encouraged us to go to the second
round of bringing 300 sorry 200 units
but each unit costs around 350 dollars
and the palestinian family can afford
the 350 dollars so we had to think again
outside of the box how can we make this
happen
if a whole neighborhood can watch
football match using one device it means
two three and four families can share
one device and enjoy the electricity
what we did is we created a new business
model called sharing is caring
sharing is caring
business model says two families share
one unit three families share one unit
and they split the cost so they can
afford paying for it
well the idea cotton i didn't expect
that but it just happened in less than
two weeks we were able to provide
over 200 people with electricity
and the question here how did the idea
catch on
we went to community centers which which
those are places you know for whom only
for men so it was so weird for women to
go there
and i told them we have a great idea we
will give you electricity you give us
people who need this electricity
now families are approaching us from all
around gaza strip i received the phone
call from the team this morning saying
maj please
we are under pressure we work 16 hours a
day we will not be able to work like
this families are calling us every
second they want solar energy
muna
one of the families we installed the
solar unit for she told me you know majd
i've never imagined i will control
something in my life
now i can control my source of energy i
feel so special
what you have
for granted is a privilege for others
people like mona
she doesn't she doesn't want to fight
she doesn't want she doesn't want to
keep to stay in in bad life she's only
looking for better life
our vision
or i would say
everyone's vision in gaza which i'm very
privileged to present the people back
home is to have a good life
future
we need to build the infrastructure of
hop
we wanted to tell them it's possible to
happen it's possible to be treated as a
human being i don't have to cross for
borders to come here you can just go to
the airport
see the people outside see how the world
looks like
thank you so much